hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel
totally just dropped a bomb they
explained their entire phase three
lineup there were a couple really big
surprises a couple things we already
knew so I'm gonna do a full breakdown
they actually played a little joke on
people if you remember everyone had been
talking about Captain America Civil War
they actually led the event by revealing
that Captain America 3 was called
serpent society and then later took it
back
ended up being civil war like civil wars
the real Captain America 3 movie they
said it was just a joke for people in a
theatre they were just having a little
bit of fun
they weren't outright trolling add to
that to that they had basically all
their biggest directors for a lot of
their phase three films sitting in the
front row there was Joss Whedon scott
derrickson who's the Doctor Strange
director the Russos who were actually
doing Captain America 3 rumored to also
be directing Avengers 3 which is now a
two-part film and Brian Michael Bendis
so lots of people then ounce let's get
to it
hello to any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
weekly Marvel videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's new
age of Ultron footage airing tonight so
I'll do a new video on that too
so here we go starting off these are the
new movies first film after ant-man is
gonna be Captain America Civil War
that's May 6 2016 so Robert Downey jr.
confirmed for the film doing cinematic
Civil War no notice I said cinematic
Civil War they said it's not so much
about secret identities like it is in
the comic book Civil War it's about who
reports to who remember Winter Soldier
was all about secret organizations
inside secret organizations accountable
to no one the Black Panther movie was
confirmed chadwick boseman will be the
actor the first time we'll see his
costume is in that movie is in Captain
America 3 movie number 2 is Doctor
Strange that's confirmed for November
4th 2016
they didn't confirm Benedict Cumberbatch
just because they're still signing his
deal they said that the only things they
announced today were things that were
carved in stone there were a lot of
rumors that dr. strange is gonna be a
2016 movie now it's just confirmed
they'll start shooting that around
spring of next year so they have a
little bit of time to finalize the actor
deal they will be filming in England
though which I know helps out because
Benedict Cumberbatch is doing a play
next year for most of the year and
filming Sherlock series 4 if Martin
Freeman can film The Hobbit and do
Sherlock then Benedict Cumberbatch can
do a Marvel movie
and sherlock at the same time - I know a
lot of people are worried about Sherlock
but deals can be made they can figure it
out movie number three is gonna be
guardians of the galaxy - they actually
moved that date it's gonna be May 5th
2017 it used to be in June so we're
actually getting to see it sooner which
is really awesome
everyone was asking Howard the Duck and
Cosmo questions but they said that once
James Gunn comes back from vacation in
Japan he'll answer those questions so
they weren't answering a lot of
guardians to questions movie number four
is Thor 3 that's Ragnarok confirmed for
July 28th 2017 Tom Hiddleston is
confirmed to be coming back as Loki
obviously he has to because he's
masquerading as Odin right now just the
idea of Ragnarok gives you the idea of
what's going on in the cinematic
universe all hell is breaking loose
literally since they're doing Ragnarok
rumored villain of course Fire Lord sir
I know everyone thought he might be the
Thor - villain but now he's here finally
so movie number 5 this was actually one
of the ones that made people go crazy
Black Panther confirmed for November 3rd
2017 like I said Chadwick Boseman
confirmed to be playing the character he
will appear in Captain America 3
obviously though so he will debut in a
cameo before he gets his solo movie this
was actually a vindication for a few
news sites cuz a couple people broke the
news last year that he was in talks just
in general I totally loved Chadwick
Boseman
I am stoked about their choice moving on
to movie number 6
so this is actually a big bombshell
Avengers 3 confirmed to be a two-part
movie it's gonna be Avengers infinity
war so everybody go crazy right now they
are doing Infinity Gauntlet or a version
of that it's just gonna be called
infinity War part 1 an infinity War part
2 it is a confirmed cross-over movie
it's a crossover event guess who it's
crossing over with you have to a knows
so which other movie does he also appear
in in a big way that's right basically
going to be the Guardians crossover
probably the second half of that movie
though unconfirmed whether or not the
Guardians will appear in both Part one
and Part two are just part two my guess
is is that he will assemble the gauntlet
in part one and do something crazy and
they'll spend the second movie trying to
fix it all moving on number 7 this was
actually the big WTF Captain Marvel
confirmed for July 6 2018 they didn't
announce an actress but it is Carol
Danvers
it's the Carol Danvers Captain Marvel
they're not doing this Marvel it will be
full on Captain Marvel they said that
they would announce an actress after
they announced the writer/director
and they're still finalizing that deal
so it's gonna be a little while before
we find out who's doing it in general
I'm really happy there were a lot of
rumors that she was gonna get a cameo in
Avengers 2 there's the mystery woman in
the trailer
that's not Carol Danvers that's a Korean
actress rumored to be involved in the
creation of Ultron another big WTF after
that movie number 8 Inhumans
I've already done a video about that so
I had a link in the description if you
guys will learn more about that that's
November 2nd 2018 and then after that
movie number nine is Avengers infinity
War part 2 that's May 3rd 2019 so they
basically announced 9 movies between
ant-man and the beginning of 2019 they
did answer a really big question they
said that they originally intended to
announce all these movies at San Diego
comic-con but a lot of deals just had
not been finalized yet and they can't
announce things until it's set in stone
a lot of people also feel like we have
Warner Brothers to thank for this
because they announced all those DC
movies I think there is a little bit of
truth to that usually movies are only
announced two to three years in advance
but this is all the way through 2019
this is crazy let me know though what do
you think about some of these movies
what do you think about chadwick boseman
playing black panther and who do you
think should play Captain Marvel
I feel like Katee Sackhoff is my number
one pick right now even just Whedon
tweeted a Photoshop pic of her as Carol
Danvers I just feel like it works it's
right just in terms of other casting
rumors too I know there's a lot of Vin
Diesel blackbolt rumors that have been
going around that's still being
finalized it's totally possible he could
do it the movie isn't gonna be happening
for a long time so they're probably
gonna focus all their Vin Diesel efforts
on guardians to on promoting that movie
just because there's so much happening
with this I will do a follow-up Q&A for
this tomorrow so just let me know what
all your questions are if you have
questions about Civil War and a lot of
people ask questions about spider-man
and Sony and that deal that might be
going on Kevin Feige said that one it's
either not true or two it's just a rumor
he was very big about it but basically I
don't think it's happening don't forget
to agents of shield tonight is gonna
premiere a new age of Ultron footage so
I'll try to do another video on that
lots of Marvel stuff happening right now
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I added a bunch of links in the
description too for my Captain America 3
Civil War Inhumans
all that extra stuff
in case you haven't seen it yet you can
click here for my benedict cumberbatch
Doctor Strange video and you can click
here to watch the age of Ultron trailer
again so good so many reasons to watch
that all day so that's all high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you